I was thinking about why I was so  fortunate to have a such a great life  and be so happy and what was making that  happen and I came to a conclusion that  it comes down to the BPP which is my big  picture patch listen I've got a lot of  stresses and a lot of things going on in  my life like anybody else we all have  headaches and there's so many things  going on in the world and so many things  to worry about  and I think a lot of its genetics and  obviously probably at the end of the day  the biggest factor in my overall  happiness in life has to come down to my  parents and what that means is that no  matter what's going on you always have  to look at the big picture the big  picture is the health and happiness of  the closest five to ten people in your  life and I have that and no matter being  on television or being really sad what I  think about that that's all I really  care about by only caring about the big  picture  it helps me live my life